Donald Trump did something yesterday
that he does on most days he went on
Twitter and he tweeted outrageous things
but there was a difference yesterday
yesterday's tweet caused numerous legal
experts to say that the tweet
constitutes criminality specifically
witness tampering
remember how Donald Trump's former
lawyer Michael Cohen pled guilty and
spilled the beans on Trump Trump didn't
like that so Trump went on Twitter and
tried to as some legal experts are
saying influenced the testimony of
another inner circle member Roger stone
who by the way has been interviewed on
the David Pakman show before Donald
Trump tweeted yesterday quote I will
never testify against Trump this
statement was recently made by Roger
stone essentially stating that he will
not be forced by a rogue and
out-of-control prosecutor to make up
lies and stories about President Trump
nice to know that some people still have
guts
so what Donald Trump is doing here is
praising a witness for not speaking to
the special counsel this is in a sense
encouraging them to continue not
speaking to prosecutor a special
prosecutor Robert Muller that is
arguably a form of witness tampering in
so doing Donald Trump also is
obstructing the progress of the
investigation
Robert Muller would carry out this
investigation speaking to Roger stone
the president is encouraging Roger stone
not to participate in that thus he is
obstructing the pursuit and carrying out
of justice that's the crime obstruction
of justice you have legal experts from
the left and from the right who are
saying yeah this likely is an illegal
attempt to influence the investigation
even Trump adviser Kellyanne Conway's
own husband George Conway says this is
illegal he quoted the president's tweet
adding just file under 18 USC
subsections 1503 and 1512 which refer to
witness tampering and
struction of Justice I actually think
that plus it's very unlikely that
there's gonna be legal consequences to
Trump for this would be great but I
think it's extraordinarily unlikely I'm
more interested in taking a slightly
zoomed out perspective and asking if
Trump is as innocent as he claims to be
why is he praising people for
obstructing justice why not just tell
the truth and get Trump out of trouble
with the truth of his complete and total
innocence in all of this and now instead
we have a building list of possible
crimes committed by Trump again I
understand he's unlikely to ever face
consequences for these but it's a pretty
big list obstruction of justice witness
tampering
perjury possibly since it seems very
likely that Donald Trump's written
answers that he's submitted to robert
muller directly contradict the testimony
of michael cohen and at this point i
tend to believe michael cohen over
donald trump Cohen has signed a plea
deal involving cooperation and truly
seems to want the best thing for his
family at this point I have no reason to
believe Michael Cohen would be lying to
Robert Muller at this point and then we
have sort of like all the other crimes
that don't even relate directly to
Donald Trump as president money
laundering for decade wire fraud and
bank fraud related to all sorts of shady
real-estate deals with Russians and
Saudis and I maintain that that Trump is
making it way worse for himself because
he won't stop tweeting I don't know if
you agree with me but I've been saying
from day one that we would only have a
fraction of the legal scenario we have
right now if from day one Donald Trump
number one never tweeted about Trump
Russia at all not a single tweet and
said only I'm cooperating I'm confident
I will be cleared I have no reason to
interfere and in the meantime I'm gonna
stay busy running the country
do you agree Pat that had he taken that
approach he wouldn't be in nearly as
much trouble as he is I totally agree
and you know there have been those
campaigns to kick Donald Trump off of
Twitter because he has been involved in
some hate speech on there and I've
always been against those campaigns
because he dug he does dig himself into
bigger holes with all this
stuff I mean a lot of what we know when
it comes to like secondary crimes
potentially committed by a Trump
obstruction of justice and witness
tampering that stems from his use of
Twitter and I think it only serves the
public good no question about it i I
don't want him to stop tweeting although
I will say that if Twitter wanted to say
Trump violates our Terms and Conditions
he's bullying people he's doing all
sorts of stuff that other people get
blocked or banned from Twitter for I
think they would have a perfectly
reasonable case to kick Trump off
Twitter I don't want them to do that I
want him to stay on Twitter and keep
digging a deeper and deeper hole one of
today's sponsors is privacy dot-com
slash Pakman this is a free service that
I've actually been using myself for a
while now and I love it you just take a
few seconds to link your debit card or
bank account to privacy coms mobile app
or browser extension for Firefox and
Chrome and what that does is allow you
to instantly create virtual credit cards
that are linked to your bank account so
that you're not actually putting your
real debit card number on the internet
and you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our
audience who signs up gets $5.00 towards
your first purchase when you sign up
using that link below